I'm not the biggest fan of word clouds
being used for any kind of statistical
measure but I do think they have their
merits they can be created fairly easily
and be understood without too much
effort so today I'm going to show you
not only how to make word clouds in R
but how to make them a bit more useful
and look better so the first thing we're
gonna do is install and load in our
packages if you don't already have the
word cloud to package installed you can
go ahead and run this line I had some
issues with the word cloud to package
when I install dot packages so I had to
get it straight from the github
repository we're also gonna load in at
the TM package which stands for text
mining which will allow us to do some
text cleaning also gonna load in reader
which will let us read in our CSV file
and of course the dir package which
allows us to do some piping and do some
other functions to work with our data
frames now I'm gonna go ahead and read
in our dataset and let me quickly show
you what this data set is so I got this
off of kaggle it's essentially a lot of
articles from medium.com
web scraped so we've got the URL of the
article the title the subtitle some
images that were used
how many claps responses and the
publication and date we're actually
gonna be building our word cloud off of
the title so you can ignore the other
columns for now but we'll kind of get
back to those a bit later now before we
can get in to actually building our word
cloud we definitely need to do some text
cleaning you can see that there are a
lot of miscellaneous punctuation and non
letter characters here there's also some
HTML over here that we need to get rid
of before we make our word cloud and
that's where the TM library comes in
because it has a lot of built-in
functions that allow us to do that text
cleaning and after we do all the text
cleaning we need to have a data frame
that essentially looks like this where
we have the column with all of our words
that are gonna go in the word cloud and
then another column with some kind of
weight or frequency where the higher the
number the larger it'll appear in the
word cloud so the first step is going to
be creating a corpus from a vector of
our text documents a corpus is
essentially just a collection of
documents and it allows us to use some
of those text cleaning functions on our
documents pretty easily so I'm gonna
created this variable called medium
corpus and we're gonna call the corpus
command that's built into the TM package
we're gonna pass in medium CSV and
use the title column once we run that we
get our medium corpus variable on the
right and then looking back at my data
frame I was telling you how there are
these HTML tags around some of our text
so I'm gonna really quickly write a
custom function to remove the HTML and
just leave what's inside so that's what
I've got right here so essentially this
function will take in some text and it's
gonna use this Jew sub command which
will take in a regular expression this
is essentially saying the first part of
the HTML tag it'll replace with an empty
string and the second part of the HTML
tag will also be replaced with an empty
string and then that text will be
returned but anyway now we're gonna go
ahead and apply some of those text
mining map functions that pretty much do
a lot of the text cleaning for us so
we're gonna grab our of medium dot
corpus variable and start doing some
piping so we'll run TM map content
transformer and we'll pass in our own
custom remove HTML function and
essentially this will take all those
titles and that original corpus and run
it through this function that I just
wrote and then we're gonna use some of
the built-in functions like remove
numbers remove punctuation strip the
whitespace convert everything to
lowercase and we're also going to remove
some stop words there are a couple of
built-in stop words that I'll show you
in a sec but I'm gonna use stop where
it's English and stop words smart so
I'll run stop where it's English and
just show you so stop words English has
a lot of these types of stop words that
we don't really want in our word cloud
stop word smart is gonna be similar it's
gonna have a lot of these common English
words that we're not gonna want in our
word cloud and just by running these
we'll get rid of a lot of unnecessary
words so once our text is sufficiently
cleaned we're gonna create a term
document matrix which is essentially a
giant matrix where each row represents a
word each column represents a document
and in the cell corresponds to how many
times the word appears in the document
to create our TDM or a term document
matrix we're gonna call the term
document matrix function and we're gonna
pass in the corpus that we just created
we're also gonna pipe this into AZ dot
matrix just to convert it to a normal
our matrix that we can work with now we
need to compute the row Y sums so we can
get a total count for each word and we
also want to sort it by how frequently
the words appear in the documents so
I'll make a new variable called words
and we're gonna set this to row sums TDM
we want it to be decreasing so the
highest number is at the top well
absolutely we're gonna make this into a
data frame that has two columns first
it's gonna be the word column that's
just gonna be the name of the words and
second is gonna be the frequency that's
gonna be the actual value of how many
times they appeared in the documents we
can run this and open up our data frame
we just created and you can see that we
get the words and their respective
frequencies but I noticed some issues I
mean there's this - up here at the top
this ' this don't that got cut off so it
looks like the text mining functions
were only able to do so much so we'll
need to go back and manually filter out
some of these rows so I'm gonna go back
to our code and manually remove some of
those rows so we're gonna pipe our data
frame into the filter command and we're
gonna filter by the rows where the word
is greater than the length of two and
it's not equal to that don't without the
t so once we run that and we go back to
our data frame you can see we got rid of
those rows and now we're working with
just normal words so we can move on to
actually creating our word cloud so this
is actually pretty simple we just need
to run the word cloud two commands and
pass in our data frame once we run that
will see our word cloud starts to
populate and be created on the right
side here there are actually a lot of
different parameters we can pass in to
our word cloud - and that's actually
what we're gonna be looking at for the
remainder of the video how to make your
word clouds look better now if you
remember what our data frame the
original data frame of the medium
articles look like there were a lot of
different publications and you can see
data is this huge word over here
learning is here but some of these
publications if we go ahead and look at
them they're not all about data
there's towards data science most likely
about data but there's also UX
collective better marketing and it's
unlikely that this word cloud is a full
representation of these seven different
publications so I think one way to make
our word cloud better is actually
separated by publication and I think for
the sake of this video I'm just gonna
look at towards data science and UX
collective just to show the contrast
between the type of titles and articles
that are being written about so
essentially we want to use word clouds
as a comparison tool rather than a
standalone thing so maybe you're
comparing five-star reviews on Amazon
with one-star reviews just to see what
the strengths and weaknesses are of a
product
regardless I do think that's separating
your word cloud by data can make them
more useful so we'll go back to our code
and at the very top here when we're
reading in our data we're just gonna add
a line to filter the publication by UX
collective so we're gonna start with
that publication and then later do
towards data science so if we run all of
our code you can see now the word cloud
looks really different
instead of data being the most common
word its design and if we change this to
two words data science and rerun all of
our code now we've got data learning
machine Python you can see that the word
clouds are now very different but we're
gonna change this back to the UX
collective and start doing some more
modifications with our word cloud so the
first thing we're gonna do is change up
the colors now right now it's using this
dark color palette but I actually looked
up what the UX collective logo looks
like and it's this polar bear with these
four or five different colors I found
this website called image color picker
calm and if I go back to this polar bear
and copy the image address I can paste
the URL here and it'll grab the image
for me so when I click on different
elements of the image it'll show me the
actual hex values of the color so I'm
gonna go back to my code and I've
grabbed the hex values of some of the
different colors and I also wanted the
background to be that nice blue color so
I'll go ahead and run these just to set
them and now I can pass in a parameter
for color so uxc colors and we're also
gonna pass in our background color uxe
background if I run this you can see
that it colored a couple of the words
but not all of them and the reason is
because this uxc colors is only of
length 3 whereas there are just so many
words so what we need to do is wrap this
around rep 1 which essentially can make
this vector the same length as the
number of words we have if we also pass
in an row number of rows about our data
frame and now when we run this you can
see that the vector of these three
colors will keep repeating over and over
so all the words are colored now another
quick improvement we can make is
changing up the font because I'm not a
huge fan of this default font so we're
gonna use the extra font library here
which will come in handy and if you
don't have this installed you can
install packages extra font the first
time you use it you'll need to run this
command font import which will
essentially import all of your system
fonts
into our so you can use them but I've
already done that and then to see what
fonts are available for you to use you
just run the fonts commands whoops let
me load in the library and that'll show
you all the system fonts you have
installed that you can use in our so I'm
gonna use this font called DM sans and
I'll just pass it in another parameter
font family and set that to DM sans I
can run this and now I have a word cloud
that doesn't look as dated as the last
one so one thing you might have noticed
is that when I ran this big design word
actually disappeared and this is because
word cloud to dynamically generates
these word clouds based on the size of
the window so if I click this button to
open up our word cloud in the browser
you can see that the design word comes
back and our word cloud looks a bit
different but if I resize this window to
something smaller and hit refresh now
that design disappears so I'm gonna
build my word cloud to fully tried and
fill the frame of this Chrome window and
in order to do that I'll have to mess
around with some of the parameters for
the word cloud so I actually did this
earlier and I found that size equals 2.5
works the best for keeping design in the
frame and I'm also gonna set the min
size to be 5 and essentially the higher
you make this number the less of these
words down here will appear so you'll
have to play with these and try to get
them exactly how you want them to make
sure that none of the words are being
cut off but yeah that is a small
annoying quirk that you're gonna have to
deal with another issue I have with this
word cloud is I don't really love the
rotation have some of these words are
straight some of them are slightly
rotated but we can set the rotate ratio
to be 0 and essentially that'll set the
probability of every word being rotated
to 0 so they're all gonna be horizonte
if we run this you can see all of our
words are horizontal it actually got rid
of a lot of the smaller words too but if
i open it in our chrome browser now we
get what the full word cob would look
like so if i want to save this image I
would just right-click and save it here
instead of using the our viewer window
which I know is cutting off a lot of
those words but I am pretty happy with
how this UX collective word cloud looks
and I'm gonna go ahead and do the same
thing essentially for the towards data
science publication just so we can get
our full final comparison of the two so
this is the towards data science logo
and this is the word cloud that I ended
up generating and now putting the two
different word clouds side-by-side you
can see they both look pretty cool they
both kind of resemble their logos and
they're obviously very different so I
think splitting up the data was
definitely a good modification we made
and just to quickly touch on the other
modifications you could make you could
actually add a mask so your letter is
only occupied certain areas of the page
this mask could be a custom image file
like a PNG there are also a different
preset shapes you can use like diamonds
or hearts and there's also a letter
cloud command which allows you to pass
in a string of text that the words in
the word cloud will take the shape of
another suggestion is to run the stem
words command on some of our text you
can see here that there's the word
design designing designer and designers
which could all be compressed into
essentially one word because they're all
really talking about the same thing and
it's actually pretty easy to do this we
would just run the TM map function again
and pass in stem document so now you see
we have one big design here instead of
all the different variations of the word
design now the issue is that we have
other words like study and expiry which
are just partial words but maybe this is
something you'd want to use in an
exploratory way just to see what kind of
topics your text is about another
suggestion would be looking into engrams
like by grams so maybe there are word
pairs that appear very frequently in
your text that you could build were
clouds off of and I'd also recommend
checking out this article by Marty Hurst
called word clouds we can't make them go
away so let's improve them and they
talked about this idea of separating
your content I've been visually dividing
it to make it more readable and
understandable so that's pretty much it
for this video and I'd recommend
checking out these other videos if
you're interested in this type of
content anyway thanks for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one